à mesure où ces parcelles circulent déjà
très très largement dans trois coups de
souris vous voulez trouver sur internet
ils ont été publiées à des dizaines de
milliers d'exemplaires pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale beaucoup de ces
exemples-là se trouve encore vous pouvez
les acheter sur cd bouquiner c'est du
mauvais papier que je vous dis mais
c'est encore là justement
doit-on publier tout ce qui se trouve en
ligne non je ne crois pas notamment
quand il s'agit de gallimard la maison
d'édition la plus prestigieuse qui soit
en france pourquoi les republier
maintenant ça n'apporte rien de positif
si ce n'est une polémique qui se fait
sur le dos de la communauté juive en
france alors que on observe tous une
montée de l'antisémitisme en france et
en europe la seule espèce de psychose
qui nous vient presque du moyen âge à
l'idée que le lycée quelque chose de
dangereux que si on lit brûle les idées
que ses livres la porte vont disparaître
moi je dis au contraire qu'il faut avoir
le courage de regarder ce cas là dedans
froidement dans un pur délice 1
quand céline dit par exemple créer même
qui clair soit favorable aux j'ai fait
qu'hitler n'aille pas assez loin
il faut s'imaginer où on est rendu là on
nous dit aussi qu'on republie bien mein
kampf mais mal quand c'est un programme
politique qui aboutit au génocide des
juifs pendant la seconde guerre mondiale
ce n'est pas le cas des pamphlets de ces
lignes les pamphlets de céline sont un
verbiage haineux envers envers les juifs
on n'est pas favorable à l'antisémitisme
d'aucune façon les conditions pour
discuter de sorts sont toujours en
réalité je ne suis pas dans les boîtes
de gallimard sig aliments qui est un
très grand éditeur dit qu'il n'a pas les
moyens pour l'instant de publier ça
conséquemment j'imagine qu'il faut
croire que gallimard
aussi décidé pour ne pas faire de
commerce sur les pamphlets antisémites
les rééditer soit avec tous ces
commentaires à noter des historiens et
que ce soit gratuit en ligne avec un bon
référencement google on peut battre les
publications antisémite